welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and for those who felt thor love
and thunder might have been missing
something your answer is written in ink
my friends loki the god of mischief's
cameo limited to the most epic back tat
and a reminder that in this 616 universe
as korg reminded us in the opening story
time prologue loki remains dead at the
hands of thanos but if you look closely
at the bottom of that tattoo the banner
reads rest and mischief and what does
rest in mischief really mean as we look
ahead in the mcu because since another
of thor's brethren who died during that
same conflict with thanos heindall now
resides in valhalla the afterlife where
asgardian warriors go when they die in
battle shouldn't logically 616 loki be
in valhalla too let's break down loki's
grid status both in the 616 mcu and what
is going on with his l1130 variant in
loki season 2 currently in production
and we are
loving it thor love and thunder
establishes the norse afterlife of
valhalla not just in the post-credits
scene but really it gets mentioned
several times throughout the movie to
remind us that it is a thing the actors
of the new asgard theater company add
dialogue to odin's party in address now
it is time for me to pass on to the
spirit realm i will take my place in the
great banquet hall of valhalla the
resting place of the gods and then later
when thor rescues sift sif says leave me
here i want to die a warrior's death on
the battlefield in battle and then i can
claim my place in valhalla and then thor
reminds us that one has to die in battle
and that since sift survived she
probably won't go there but maybe her
severed arm is in valhalla then again
the rule does seem a bit fuzzy on this
odin disintegrated into golden dust and
ragnarok despite not being in the midst
of battle in that moment i guess he
could argue that he was in a way
fighting a war against the rising
threats of hela or thanos or maybe
fighting his own guilty conscience but
no that's not how valhalla works i guess
it's also possible that turning into
gold and dust doesn't necessarily mean
true valhalla you go the dust is just
what it looks like from our perspective
when god tier beans leave this plane of
existence and go elsewhere to valhalla
or wherever else case in point heindall
he didn't turn into gold dust when
thanos killed him and his soul
nonetheless ended up in valhalla so i
think we can safely say that the gold
dust isn't a required component of the
transfer to valhalla it's just something
that coincidentally was the case for
jane foster and we cannot deny that 616
loki died in the midst of a heroic
battle thanos's forces slaughtering half
the asgardian refugees that was a
genuine war my friends an infinity one
and loki lunged at thanos neck with a
dagger to prevent it in his final
breaths loki rest two thanos
[Music]
and looking back it's hard not to see
that as an obi-wan kenobi style if you
strike me down i shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
this was 616 loki's final taunt take my
body away but since i'm a god a true god
not a weird pseudo god of an eternal
variety as thanos is and since my death
came because i tried to save my people
from you i know where i'm going an
eternal reward awaits me one of those
mormony looking banquet halls now when
loki variant l1130 gets pruned in loki
episode 4 he wakes up in the void and
asks
this is hell hell with one l meaning
loki expected that when he died he
wouldn't have gone to valhalla he would
have gone to hell the realm hella was
banished too but this variant up until
that point had been more goofus than
gallant he hadn't yet heroically engaged
in any serious gallantry that would come
later in episode five and perhaps
motivated by this come to odin moment
that if he's going to die he should do
so in a blaze of glory protecting those
he loves now of course that loki lives
on in the loki's series with the tda
season one ended with loki shaken from
his encounter with the kang variant he
who remains and silvi rupturing the
sacred timeline in a way that left loki
in a warped tva where kang rules over it
proudly declining the use of the visage
of timekeepers mobius and p15 in this
work tva don't recognize loki their
memories white not just from their
recent experiences with him but they
don't even recognize him as the infamous
god of mischief and now we're beginning
to see some set imagery from loki's
season two showing loki back in tva
agent uniform as they visit a 1970s
mcdonald's sylvia's working there the
orange uniform she wears was dated to a
1976 mcdonald's uniform maybe they're
trying to track down sylvie from yet
another timeline after the season one
event who knows since time is a flat
circle maybe we're just gonna see a
repeat of the season one events with a
different variant of all these people
doomed to repeat themselves over and
over again as from a broad bird's eye
view the timeline is rupturing and they
are all doomed to end up at the same
destination i can't wait to break down
loki's season 2. so is that what rest
and mischief really means or does it
refer to our 616 loki who is currently
residing in valhalla now i don't have to
tell you that inflation makes everything
cost more and that stinks but if you
could get some of your hard-earned cash
back it would stink less right well
that's where upside comes in upside's an
app that gets you up to three times more
cash back than a credit card loyalty
program can for stuff you buy all the
time here's an example gas when i need
gas i open up the upside app i search
for a nearby gas station operate a good
deal claim it and then head there to buy
gas i can check in or snap a pic of the
receipt and i'm good to go no special
cards to carry or numbers to remember
just upside zap on my phone anytime i
want i can cash out to my bank account
paypal or an egift card for amazon and
other brands upside users are earning
more than a million dollars every week
and it has a 4.8 star rating on the app
store to get started download the free
upside app in the app store or google
play use promo code new rockstars and
get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of 10 or more and
thanks again to upside for sponsoring
this video one of the things i missed
out on with the mcu version of ragnarok
is how truly revolutionary this event is
supposed to be to the asgardians in the
movie ragnarok is really the prophesized
doom of asgard mentioned by surtur and
confirmed by odin before his death and
then later just allowed to happen by
thor and loki unleashing searcher to
destroy asgard and take out hela but
many of the asgardians survived that
event escaped on the refugee ship the
statesman until half of those refugees
are killed by thanos's forces and
another half of them are wiped out off
screen in the snap it's likely that many
of the citizens of new asgard interpret
all of these events as a season of
ragnarok the way many people in our
world look at a bunch of national
tragedies and strokes of bad luck as
some kind of coming apocalypse but at
the end of the day that was not truly
ragnarok used in the comics which take
their cues from norse mythology ragnarok
is meant to be a truly apocalyptic event
that cyclically kills all of the
asgardians including thor they are all
destined to die after ragnarok and the
marvel comics the asgardian souls are
reincarnated into new bodies this is
actually how we get lady loki because
loki's reincarnated soul snatches the
female body that was meant for lady sith
meanwhile lady loki traps sif in the
body of an elderly woman confined to a
nursing home and this leads to some
humorous confusion with thor and lady
loki goes on to become a major player
during the dark reigns storyline of the
comics and this is why i was so excited
to see valhalla now because seeing
afterlife forms of dead characters at
all suggest that sentient souls are a
thing and post ragnarok reincarnation
may also be in the cards for upcoming
mcu titles in loki's case one of the
other times he reincarnated in the
comics was in 2011 when he was reborn as
a boy in paris with no memories of being
loki except for some nightmares in which
he does frightening things thor takes
his kid under his wing and restores part
of his identity and this kid goes on to
become the little punk anti-hero kid
loki now to be clear this is not the
same kid loki whom we met in the void in
the disney plus series that was a
different loki who killed thor when they
were children no reincarnation was
involved there so within 616 we could
get loki reborn and this would be a
different way to bring back dead
characters than this other way that
they've been doing through multiversal
variants the main difference being those
variants do not have the memories of the
characters and the past relationships
with the living characters from the
infinity saga and that shared history is
really what i think makes these
characters special the battles they
fought together the losses they've
shared loki variant l130 didn't live
through the events of the dark world or
ragnarok or infinity war with or he just
kind of watched it all on a projector
screen is watching something on the
screen equal character development i
mean i don't know when i watch wanda
reenact sitcom tropes with the
synthezoid am i vicariously growing as a
person with her i'm crying just as hard
as what is grief if not love persevering
am i equally corruptable to an evil book
if i happen to read it really the
question we should be asking doesn't
death give life meaning and by suddenly
resurrecting all these characters were
robbing them of the important moment of
their deaths yes of course death gives
life meaning but as the mcu goes deeper
into afterlives and existentialism by
resurrecting these dead characters it
really recalls the words of t'challa
when he first described the ancestral
plane back in civil war in my culture
dead
it's not the end
it's marve
stepping off point so i would say as
long as the death fully transforms this
soul in a lasting meaningful way in
their afterlife and in their
reincarnated future that transformation
means the meaning that stays intact so
yes loki should be in valhalla my
friends and yes the sun should rise on
these brothers once again you can follow
me on instagram and twitter avos
following rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you